Kanye West causing a lot of controversy
on the Internet have you heard about
this yeah thank you for validating it a
woman a woman right here went yes go
ahead Conan no big story today Kanye
West tweeted lots of praise for
president Trump tweeted a lot of praise
for president Trump yeah he's wearing
the Hat yeah yeah Kanye called Trump my
brother and Trump and Trump called Kanye
my one black supporter make America
great hat and everything what else is
going on today French president McCrone
told Congress he disagrees with
President Trump on the Iran nuclear deal
and on climate change yeah McCrone said
but other than things that could destroy
the entire world we're on the same page
so it's all happy and then they made out
again they're kissing each other a lot
they were there was a lot of touching
yeah a lot of touching a lot of kissing
a lot it's true they keep buying each
other now I know there's kissing I
didn't get actually like that till I was
35 third body language experts say that
all the touching between presidents
Trump and McCrone was an exercise in
primate primate like male dominance yes
and here's the good news for Americans
apparently our baboon won
yeah
[Music]
he's more of an orangutan yeah it's
being reported that Veterans
Administration nominee dr. Ronnie
Jackson is known as the Candyman in the
White House because he gave out
prescriptions like candy yeah so now we
can all stop asking ourselves how does
Melania do it good now she's with you in
the wheelbarrow there's a new royal baby
that's exciting I know yeah Andi
pretending to be excited about the Wow
you could you could give a [ __ ] I'm so
excited about it yeah anyway book makers
book makers are giving odds on the royal
baby's new name and the name that came
in dead last is Wayne that came in
laughs Wayne as the least likely name
yeah which is too bad cuz I'd love to
hear the Royal Guards say please rise
for His Royal Highness Lil Wayne
[Applause]
you